hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to whispers another indie
horror game for the oculus rift and this
one actually has quite a bit of detail
put into it not only in the art which
looks pretty nice back yeah what did I
do oh I did something okay
I think my calibration just went off
what did I do to calibrate huh grabbing
it oh god what am i doing
Oh recalibrate recalibrate think I'm
good now now that the crisis is over I'm
gonna say that this game actually looks
quite good even though I got a nest of
wires in front of me I'm gonna try my
best not to crap my pants as I'm going
through this dark and dangerous dungeon
or darkenator sewer this seems to be
flashing lights and fog how boring and
droll we're gonna have to come up with
something original to scare the pants
off of me and that task might be harder
than it seems because as everyone
probably already knows by now I don't
play games with pants on hi uh uh okay
that was disturbingly normal hello baby
assuming you were a lady oh whoa
that's something over there okay I got a
few things that I need to wrap my head
around before we move forward what is
that what are that and what are over
there hello mr. skeleton dude are you
doing why do you have your intestines oh
you have your eyeballs that's weird
weird there's an even bigger skull over
there bag
thank you let's go with that lady 1
still I still think something over there
and I don't much care for it and I don't
know what it is about this particular
game but it seems to have quite the
atmosphere there's another dead dude at
least I hope he's dead don't know if
he's a skeleton or what Oh another
Skellington like I wasn't dead mother ok
now this game is just [ __ ] with me
I don't know much care for things
sticking with me hello Skellington how's
it hanging whoa are you real
whoa you back off are you real or you
will
are you real you better tell me right
now Frank you're my tummy right now
assume he wasn't or anything else oh god
damn alright I go this way well so they
got jumpscares hand me what else do they
got they got a wall we got another one
I've just run oh it is by me okay god I
was more worried than there wasn't gonna
be Sun behind me ok grudge much I still
hear something yeah ok
this game has won a lot of games off and
don't especially in the horror genre
it's good sound sounds good
sounded key I was playing uh game dev
simulator whatever was cool
I'm not gonna go that way
ah blue to go this way where there's
light and stuff maybe this is loops back
around to the other paths that I didn't
take before in the beginning
anyway when I was playing game dev
simulator back while ago now make horror
games all the time
you're easy to make and sound whose
paramount in them God where am I going
I don't even know where this is anymore
where the hell okay that's a bit ah
alright then
I'm too familiar horn jump scare sound
can all get the way y'all get all I get
me with that like ten hundred more times
for I Scott get really angry so which
way am I supposed to go didn't right Ian
don't know where I'm going I don't know
what I'm doing I don't know why I'm
doing it all I know that I'm doing it
with all the best power I can mother me
write me run that by me again
do I hear funny footsteps behind me I
hear footy footsteps in front of me
[ __ ] your vines where am i new
okay another one well that's a key okay
I picked up a key that's okay that was
hard well I don't want to know what's in
the spider cobwebs over there ain't no
likey oh okay
did I use the key on that I really don't
want to go down there but I know you
guys would be remiss if I didn't Tommy
to go oh it's a supply is anybody afraid
of spiders this thing is really close to
my face whew
hello spider what the spider phobia also
known as rakhna phobia for non idiots
again so those were I thought that was
like ghosty ectoplasmic goo that got
shot all over the walls by Randy Marsh
but uh no he's actually spider webs I
thought I was being stupid and clutter
clever stupid lever clue fit whatever is
being me okay I was just checking
something wasn't actually happening it
was just that it decided that I needed
to see Oh Oh nuts nuts again what am i
doing now this is where I die oh that
was it no it was a very very short demo
God Mac I was just getting into it piss
okay
so anyway that was whispers part one
they told me it was a short demo going
into it I just didn't knows that short
but either way there's a lot of
potential here but I gotta say I have to
say this after playing a lot of these
games I recognize the horror sounds are
being used over and over and over again
there needs to be some originality to it
and just like me that I played so many
of these I need like something new even
though you still got me a lot with them
like I was hoping for something new
either way still good a lot of potential
can't wait to see the finished product
so if you enjoyed this video leave a
like down below let me know in the
comments have you got any more oculus
rift or horror games you want me to play
and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye doctor yeah
football
called you here today because well
there's no easy way to say this hardest
part of my day